some 250 Muslims turned out to
demonstrate in front of Austria's
Parliament many belong to the network
Muslims civil society it was set up last
October to discuss the governing
coalition's plan for a new Islam law its
members feel that they're being
discriminated against they say that the
law marginalizes the Muslim community
rather than promoting integration these
young Muslims reject any form of state
control over their religion its docking
it's in Austria all Muslims are treated
with latent suspicion and that's
reflected in this law the law also
touches on many aspects of security
policy what's worse is the tone that the
law dons the fact that it expressly
states in a religious law things that go
without saying things that are already
encoded in law about endangering the
public order or the health of citizens
or whatever it is Debbie's in I'm
religions Cosette's did the new law
obliges public institutions to offer
food in line with Muslim regulations
Islamic holidays will also be recognized
although the legislation stops short of
making them paid public holidays
controversially the legislation also
prohibits foreign funding for Imams from
2016 opponents want the country's
Constitutional Court to investigate
whether that infringes on the right to
equal treatment before the law the
government has dismissed these concerns
justice it's the law is not an
anti-terror law and it's not a law to
tackle Islamophobia the law is a law for
the Muslim communities for Islam in
Austria Misha Collins kamancheh food and
Islam in Easter day it remains to be
seen what impact the law will have on
Austrian Muslims